des années que cette boucherie n'avait
pas vu autant client quelqu'un pousse à
bout c'est bon derrière le comptoir
alexandre fargeau éleveurs bovins il y à
peine quatre mois avec six autres
producteurs ils ont décidé de reprendre
la seule boucherie du village qui allait
fermer son repreneur
presque un geste citoyen pour lui qui a
toujours vécu ici les commerces ferment
les uns après les autres et si on
n'avait pas sauté le pas ben
peut-être que
on aurait continué un petit peu une
petite diversification comme un sport
commerce c'est à nous aussi de habitants
ruraux de relancer aussi la machine peut
pas que
que se plaindre il faut aussi montés au
créneau depuis relancer les affaires des
affaires sans intermédiaire la viande et
la charcuterie ont à peine parcouru
quelques kilomètres avant d'être vendus
un circuit court
l'évolution naturelle du métier pour
l'ancien boucher venus prêter main forte
quelle bonne initiative de la part des
producteurs
c'est l'avenir à mon avis les gens sont
depuis de plus en plus demandeurs de
produits comme ceux ci des produits
locaux donc je pense que
ça marchera un pronostic très largement
partagé par les habitants du secteur
préfèrent acheter des produits c'est
bouché en direct que les appeler
directement supermarché j'ai fait quinze
kilomètres pour venir important de faire
l'effort c'est une initiative vraiment
formidable parce que la disparition d'un
commerce dans une finale c'est une mort
lente face aux fluctuations des cours de
la viande aux difficultés quotidiennes
pour les producteurs la nouvelle
boutique c'est aussi une respiration
ça valait vraiment plus trop pourquoi on
se levait le matin quand c'était
vraiment produisez et
le prix c'était au bon vouloir de
l'acheteur alors qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui on se lève le matin on
identifie les consommateurs et ça c'est
très très cher à nos yeux
[Musique]
on travaille vraiment pour des
consommateurs finaux et pour nous c'est
très important
selon les chiffres du ministère de
l'agriculture en france aujourd'hui
un éleveur sur 10 devant une partie de
sa production en circuit court